Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
Hoy quiero comenzar
donde nos quedamos la clase pasada.
Hablábamos, en el contexto del
libro de Jonathan Shay,
Achilles In Vietnam,
de las consecuencias que surgen
cuando las personas,
debido a las circunstancias, actúan
de formas que su pensamiento
considera inmorales o injustas.
En 1961, apareció en los
periódicos de la zona de New Haven
el siguiente anuncio.
Decía: "Al público en general.
Pagamos 4 USD" (esto era bastante
dinero para la época)
"4 USD por una hora de su tiempo.
Se buscan personas para un
estudio de memoria.
Pagaremos a 500 personas de New
Haven para que nos ayuden
a realizar un estudio científico sobre
la memoria y el aprendizaje.
El estudio se realizará en la
Universidad de Yale.
Cada participante recibirá 4 USD más
0.50 USD para el transporte
a cambio de una hora de su
tiempo aproximadamente.
Solamente los necesitamos
durante una hora.
Sin más obligaciones.
Pueden elegir el horario en el
que les gustaría venir,
tardes, fines de semana o entre semana".
El anuncio continuaba:
"no se requiere capacitación
especial, estudios o experiencia".
Buscaban "obreros de fábricas,
empleados de la ciudad, peones,
peluqueros, hombres de negocio,
administrativos, profesionistas,
empleados de telefonía,
albañiles, vendedores,
personal de oficinas y otros".
La gente que respondió al anuncio
fue citada en este edificio
que a ustedes les debe parecer conocido.
Era el edificio Linsley-Chittenden Hall.
Cuando entraron al edificio
se encontraron con el
estudio de este señor.
El anuncio que acabo de mostrarles
era para reclutar a sujetos
para participar en el famoso
estudio de Milgram.
Los participantes rellenaron el cupón
que aparecía debajo del anuncio
y vinieron al laboratorio en el edificio
que hoy se conoce como
Linsley-Chittenden Hall.
La disposición del edificio era
distinta en esa época,
pero la fachada era magnífica y el
laboratorio era elegante.
Cuando los sujetos entraron al
laboratorio se les dijo
que participarían en un estudio
de aprendizaje y memoria,
y que podrían jugar uno de los
dos papeles disponibles.
Podrían ser el maestro o el alumno.
Aunque cuando sorteaban los
papeles doblados,
ambos decían "maestro" y
el otro sujeto,
que supuestamente también
participaba en el estudio,
era en realidad un colaborador.
Cuando el estudio se realizó,
los sujetos que desempeñaron
el papel de maestro
fueron 40 hombres de la
zona de New Haven
que habían respondido a este anuncio,
con edades de 20 a 50 años
y con una variedad de
ocupaciones y niveles
educativos.
A todos se les dijo que
participarían en una tarea
para estudiar el papel del
castigo en el aprendizaje.
Se les dijo que el otro
sujeto, el alumno,
era un contador de 47 años,
estadounidense de origen irlandés,
al que la mayoría de ellos
describió como atento y simpático.
El alumno recibiría una serie
de pares de palabras
y la tarea del maestro era simplemente
darle una descarga eléctrica
cada vez que se equivocara.
Había otra persona para
supervisar el estudio,
el experimentador, una persona
severa e impasible,
de 31 años, un profesor de
biología de secundaria.
En todos los casos,
2 sujetos eran los mismos, el
experimentador y el alumno,
solo variaba el maestro.
La tarea era la siguiente.
Se presentaba al maestro una máquina
con una serie de
interruptores que comenzaban
en
"descarga eléctrica ligera":
15, 30, 45, 60 voltios;
continuaba con incrementos de 15:
75, 90, 105, 120, etc.
hasta llegar a "descarga eléctrica
intensa": 255, 270, 285, 300;
después "peligro: descarga grave";
y por último (no busquen
esto en Google) "XXX".
Los maestros recibieron una
descarga eléctrica
de 45 voltios supuestamente
generada por la máquina.
La mayoría calculó que
había sido de 70 voltios.
O sea que sintieron bastante
intensa la descarga.
Después se les dijo que tenían que dar
una descarga al alumno cada
vez que se equivocara.
Antes de hacer el estudio, Milgram
encuestó a unos alumnos de Yale de la
especialidad de psicología
que cursaban su último año y
les pidió que predijeran
cuántas descargas serían
capaces de dar los maestros.
En este gráfico pueden
ver que se predijo
que no más del 3% de los sujetos
daría descargas en el nivel 20,
que es de bajo nivel de peligro
y que casi nadie llegaría
al nivel más alto.
Sin embargo, como ya sabemos,
el 100% de los maestros
dieron las descargas ligeras
de 15, 30, 45 y 60.
El 88% llegó a las descargas intensas
de 255, 270, 285 y 300.
Cuando ya no querían continuar,
el experimentador les decía
"por favor, continúe",
"el experimento requiere que continúe",
"es completamente
imprescindible que
continúe"
o "no tiene otra opción,
debe continuar",
pero no se les daba otro
tipo de motivación.
Sin embargo, el 68% llegó al nivel
de "peligro: descarga grave"
y el 65% llegó hasta el último nivel.
Esto es lo que normalmente se destaca
del experimento de Milgram
y el insólito aspecto de
los seres humanos
que Milgram quería estudiar,
porque esta posibilidad se acababa
de demostrar por completo
en el mundo fuera del laboratorio.
La investigación de
Milgram era un intento
por entender cómo se podría
explicar el comportamiento
de los ciudadanos alemanes
comunes en la Alemania nazi.
Ahora quiero explicar
la discusión posterior al
estudio de Milgram
que acabo de presentar.
Me refiero al tema de qué sentían,
subjetivamente estos sujetos
cuando pensaban que estaban
lastimando a la otra persona.
En esta diapositiva pueden ver
que muchos pensaban que
estaban lastimando al otro.
La respuesta psicológica de los
sujetos se parece a lo que leímos
en el libro de Jonathan Shay
para la clase pasada.
Muchos sujetos mostraron
"señales de nerviosismo,
especialmente al administrar las
descargas más poderosas.
En una gran cantidad de casos, el
grado de tensión alcanzó
extremos rara vez vistos en estos
sujetos de laboratorio.
Sudaban, tartamudeaban, se
mordían los labios,
gemían, se clavaban las
uñas en la piel, etc."
Estas eran respuestas
comunes, no excepcionales.
Si nunca han visto los
videos que hizo Milgram
de los experimentos, que no son
de dominio público,
pero les diré que en Internet
pueden escuchar la tranquila
voz del experimentador
y notar la agitación de los sujetos.
Aquí hay una descripción.
Dice Milgram en su informe:
"uno se imaginaría
que un sujeto se
detendría o continuaría
según le dictara su conciencia.
Pero no fue así.
Hubo asombrosas reacciones de
tensión y presión emocional.
Un observador declaró:
'Vi entrar a un hombre de
negocios, maduro
y con aplomo, al laboratorio.
Sonreía y se veía seguro de sí mismo.
En 20 min. se había venido abajo,
temblaba y tartamudeaba.
Se jalaba constantemente el
lóbulo de la oreja.
Retorcía sus manos.
En algún momento, se apretó
la frente con el puño
y murmuró: "Dios mío, ya no más".
Aun así, continuó respondiendo
a cada palabra del experimentador y
obedeció hasta el final'".
Es algo raro de los seres humanos.
Por un lado, parecemos tener un sentido
de lo que podemos soportar cómodamente.
Pero, por otro lado, tenemos la
habilidad de ir más allá.
Esa capacidad puede ser
explotada para bien o para mal.
Quienes practican deportes
conocen la experiencia
de superar lo que pensaban
que podría ser su límite y
continuar aguantando
a pesar de que al inicio
parecía imposible.
Siempre pasa que
terminamos llevando a cabo
aquellas cosas que nos molestan.
Pero esto trae
consecuencias
psicológicas.
Esa es la segunda
respuesta que quiero dar,
en el contexto de la clase del
témis, al reto de Glaucón.
Quiero explicar el tema de hoy,
la prosperidad y el apego,
a través de una variación de
los estudios de Milgram.
Cuando Milgram obtuvo estos resultados
en su estudio de 1961 le
surgió esta duda:
¿bajo qué circunstancias era más o
menos probable la obediencia?
Milgram hizo un estudio de
seguimiento el siguiente año,
explorando esa pregunta de la
forma más general.
La forma más general era:
Si X le dice a Y que lastime a Z,
¿bajo qué condiciones Y
obedecerá la orden de X? y
¿bajo qué condiciones se
negará a obedecer?
En la investigación de laboratorio
la pregunta se convierte en: si un
experimentador pide a un sujeto
que lastime a otra persona,
¿bajo qué condiciones el sujeto
obedecerá esta orden?
y ¿bajo qué condiciones se
negará a obedecer?
Milgram comenzó a estudiar esto
variando en un continuo
el grado de interacción
humana en el estudio.
En una serie de estudios,
el experimentador que les daba
la orden de continuar
estaba en el mismo cuarto que ellos,
o les daba las
instrucciones por
teléfono
o los sujetos solo recibían las
instrucciones por escrito.
La tendencia de los sujetos a
colaborar, cooperar,
hacer lo que se les pedía,
disminuía directamente
si el que recibía la descarga estaba
en el mismo cuarto que ellos.
Milgram también varió el
nivel de respuesta
que el sujeto tenía
de la persona que
recibía las descargas.
En la condición remota
no recibían ninguna respuesta.
O recibían una respuesta auditiva,
como en los experimentos iniciales,
escuchaban a la persona gritar al
otro lado de la pared:
"Me duele, me lastima. Por favor, pare".
O estaban en el mismo cuarto y
veían sufrir al sujeto.
Finalmente, la condición más extrema
era que tenían que agarrar
el brazo del sujeto
y ponerlo en una placa de metal
y sostenerlo ahí para
darle la descarga.
Milgram descubrió que la obediencia
era muy alta cuando no recibían
respuesta del que sufría,
pero era más baja cuando
escuchaban su voz,
aún más baja cuando estaban
en el mismo cuarto
y mucho más baja cuando tenían que
usar su cuerpo para lastimarlo.
Recordarán que en la primera
clase, la de introducción,
cuando les explicaba el
tipo de preguntas
que discutiríamos en este
semestre, les di el ejemplo
del problema del tranvía, en
el que un tranvía
va a toda velocidad por una vía y
se dirige hacia 5 personas.
En la primera versión de ese caso,
les pregunté si sería moralmente
aceptable desviar el tranvía
para que fuera por otra vía en la
que solo había una persona.
La mayoría pensaba que
estaba bien hacerlo.
En la segunda versión,
les pregunté si sería
correcto detener el tranvía
aventando a las vías a un hombre gordo
que estaba parado en un puente
situado encima de las vías.
La mayoría consideró que
eso no estaba bien.
Hay algo en la percepción humana
de nuestras interacciones
con los otros que parece
despertar ansiedad
si tenemos que ver los
daños que causamos.
Milgram lo explica de esta manera.
Dice: "En la condición remota,
y en menor medida en la
condición de respuesta auditiva,
la víctima tiene una cualidad abstracta
y remota para el sujeto.
El sujeto es consciente, pero
solo de forma conceptual".
Su razón lo sabe, siguiendo la
terminología de Platón, pero
las otras partes de su alma no se han
dado cuenta de lo que pasa.
Milgram continúa: "Este
fenómeno es bastante común.
El bombardero puede suponer
de forma razonada
que sus armas van a causar
sufrimiento y muerte.
De hecho, matan a tanta gente
como las bayonetas.
Pero este conocimiento está
despojado de afecto
y no tiene una respuesta emocional
al sufrimiento causado
por sus acciones".
Se han hecho observaciones
similares en tiempos de guerra.
Ver el sufrimiento de las víctimas
provoca respuestas empáticas en el
sujeto y le proporcionan
un conocimiento más completo de la
experiencia de la víctima.
Una de las principales
estrategias de la Alemania nazi
para facilitar que la gente
dañara a sus vecinos
consistía en usar un
lenguaje deshumanizado
para referirse a los grupos dañados:
los judíos, los gitanos, los
homosexuales, etc.
De cierta manera, se deshumanizaban.
Cuando percibimos a otro como humano
es difícil superar la
inclinación a no querer
lastimarlo.
Aunque les he dado muchos ejemplos
de cómo la resistencia militar
puede ser un mecanismo poderoso
para luchar por nuestra voluntad,
este hecho que Milgram observó
es donde se basa
realmente la posibilidad
de otro tipo de resistencia,
que en algunos casos ha sido
increíblemente eficaz.
Aquí está Gandhi,
participando en protestas no
violentas en la India en 1940.
Aquí hay una sentada en la
barra de un bar en Selma,
Alabama en 1963.
Por supuesto, aquí está una de
las imágenes más famosas
de las últimas 2 décadas.
Una persona parada ante los tanques
para impedirles continuar avanzando
en la Plaza de Tiananmen.
¿Por qué los seres humanos
ignoramos más fácilmente las
demandas de una persona
cuando no está presente?
¿Por qué nos cuesta más
trabajo seguir las órdenes
cuando vemos la cara de la persona a
la que estamos lastimando?
Lo que pasa, y no es ninguna
sorpresa, es que los seres humanos
somos fundamental y
completamente seres sociales.
Somos entidades sociales
y eso se extiende a nuestros
antecesores primates no humanos.
Harry Harlow, en la primera
mitad del siglo,
hizo una serie de estudios
usando primates no humanos
para intentar descubrir el papel que
juegan los lazos afectivos
y sociales en la prosperidad.
En el famoso estudio de madres de
alambre contra madres de trapo,
aquí tenemos a un participante, a los
monos se les presentaban 2 seres
de alambre con quienes
podían pasar tiempo.
La madre de alambre tenía leche
y tenían que ir con ella
para obtener comida,
pero la madre de trapo
ofrecía consuelo,
si querían sentirse tranquilos
tenían que ir con ella.
Todos los monos hicieron lo
que ven en la imagen.
El hecho de que digan "Oh..."
es una muestra de lo que
intento explicar.
Pensamos que esto es encantador.
Es muy difícil controlar
los músculos faciales al
ver esta imagen.
¿Verdad?
Todos vemos esos enormes
ojos llenos de calidez
y esta expresión de cariño.
Para que la experiencia de
maduración de los primates
sea sana y próspera
es indispensable que tengan contacto
social en etapas tempranas.
De hecho,
algunos estudios más
polémicos moralmente de Harlow
implicaban someter a monos jóvenes a
una total privación social
y descubrió que al
suprimir la privación,
su comportamiento no era compatible
con la vida en comunidad.
Eran hostiles y agresivos
con sus coetáneos
y también eran incapaces de criar
a los hijos que tenían.
Uno se pregunta al igual que
el alumno de Harlow,
John Bowlby, y su
colaboradora, Mary
Ainsworth,
si hay algo que los seres
humanos necesitan
para prosperar que podamos
deducirlo de estos estudios
de Harlow de las madres de
alambre y de trapo.
¿Es posible que para
desarrollarnos los seres humanos
necesitemos de una interacción
cálida que no se limite
simplemente a recibir los nutrientes
indispensables para la maduración
a través de una madre de alambre?
Esta tabla es de un sitio web
llamado "Positive Parenting"
(crianza positiva) y quiero que vean
la influencia de los estudios
de Bowlby y Ainsworth en las
ideas contemporáneas
de cómo es apropiado criar a los hijos.
Mary Ainsworth puso a niños
pequeños, de 2 años más o menos,
en un escenario de laboratorio
con su cuidador primario.
Quería descubrir qué tan cómodos
estaban los niños en una
situación extraña,
en la que necesitarían
comenzar por sí mismos,
alejados de su cuidador, a jugar con
unos juguetes atractivos.
Con base en ello, identificó 3
– ahora se han ampliado a 4 –
3 estilos de apego de los niños
hacia sus cuidadores.
El primero, llamado apego seguro,
se deriva de la experiencia de la
temprana infancia que supone
una receptividad previsible hacia
las necesidades propias
por parte de alguien que
nos tiene afecto.
Si tenemos hambre, alguien
responde dándonos comida.
Si algo nos duele, alguien responde
consolándonos en nuestro dolor.
Si tenemos frío, alguien
responde dándonos calor.
Esto sucede de tal forma
que nos creamos una
impresión de nosotros mismos
como agentes en el mundo cuyas
expresiones de necesidades
y deseos pueden generar respuestas
de otros seres conscientes
ante nuestras necesidades y deseos.
El mundo se vuelve un lugar donde la
confianza social es posible,
los primeros instintos que tenemos,
cuando vemos caras y
cuerpos de congéneres,
nos permiten adoptar un patrón
de respuesta primitivo
en el que esperamos, si no hay
evidencia contraria,
que esos congéneres serán receptivos
a la expresión de nuestras
necesidades sinceras.
Por otra parte, un pequeño
porcentaje de niños presentaron
lo que Ainsworth denominó
apego evitativo.
No querían explorar el cuarto
y eso pasaba, según la
hipótesis de Ainsworth,
porque su temprana infancia
había sido desligada o
distante con su cuidador.
Ante la expresión de necesidad,
no tenían la sensación de que si
había otro ente social
este respondería a aquello que pedían.
Desarrollaron la
sensación de que el mundo
no es un lugar seguro y cooperativo.
El tercer grupo estaba compuesto por
niños con apego ambivalente.
Los niños con apego ambivalente
vivieron un régimen de respuesta
en el que a veces se
respondía a sus necesidades
y a veces se les ignoraba por completo.
No tenían la sensación
de que el mundo nunca hace
lo que le pides,
pero sí tenían la
sensación de que el mundo
no respondía de forma
confiable a sus necesidades.
Por último, en la cuarta
categoría agregada después,
estaban los niños que no
solo eran ignorados
sino abusados o maltratados ante la
expresión de una necesidad.
Esta taxonomía no tiene un
nivel de precisión
que nos permita decir fácilmente en
qué categoría entra cada niño
como resultado del trato que recibe.
Hay muchas cuestiones sobre las
disposiciones innatas
que tienen los niños y en
muchos casos no queda claro
cómo poner a los niños
dentro de esta taxonomía.
No obstante, ha servido de base para
uno de los estudios científicos
más extraordinarios
realizados en el siglo pasado.
Un estudio longitudinal de 30
años hecho por personas
que estudiaron seriamente el apego,
que observaron la medida en que se
podría predecir el desarrollo
y la prosperidad basándose en la
experiencia de la temprana infancia.
Este libro, The Development of the
Person (que leí en el verano)
es extraordinario en el sentido que
muestra lo que se necesita
para establecer una complicada
hipótesis científico social
con un grado de certeza equilibrado.
Si quisiéramos estudiarlos a ustedes
para saber si sus experiencias
en la temprana infancia afectaron
en su desarrollo posterior
ya no podemos, porque perdimos
nuestra máquina para
viajar en el tiempo.
La dejamos en el futuro.
No podemos volver y observar
cómo fue su infancia.
Todos estos estudios se
tenían que hacer a futuro.
Este grupo estudió a cientos
y cientos de niños,
haciendo un esfuerzo
increíble por seguirlos
incluso cuando se mudaran.
Y la conclusión básica que obtuvieron,
el libro tiene cientos de páginas,
pero la conclusión
básica que obtuvieron
confirma la hipótesis de la
teoría del apego.
Las experiencias en la primera infancia,
especialmente las relaciones receptivas
y de confianza, determinan
significativamente
los patrones posteriores de
respuesta al mundo.
Obviamente, ya han escuchado esto antes.
Cuando nos dijeron: "es importante
adquirir bien algún
hábito desde jóvenes.
De hecho, es importantísimo".
Esto no significa que
quienes no hayan tenido
las experiencias óptimas en
la temprana infancia
nunca vayan a prosperar o
a desarrollarse.
El espíritu humano es
extraordinariamente fuerte y es
posible,
mediante ciertos tipos de terapias
o mediante el cultivo de
relaciones de confianza,
superar la privación de la
temprana infancia.
Pero, hay un camino más
fácil para prosperar,
es el que pasa por una temprana
infancia con confianza.
El hecho de que los seres
humanos somos seres sociales
nos afecta no solo al inicio de nuestras
vidas sino también al final.
Jonathan Haidt dice: "Si
quieres predecir
qué tan feliz es una persona o
cuántos años puede llegar a vivir,
deberías investigar sus
relaciones sociales.
Tener buenas relaciones sociales
fortalece el sistema inmunológico.
Prolonga la vida más que
dejar de fumar.
Acelera la recuperación
de una cirugía,
reduce el riesgo de
depresión y ansiedad".
Las interrelaciones sociales son vitales
para la prosperidad humana.
Esto no es algo que hayamos
descubierto solo en occidente.
Aquí hay algunos títulos de
artículos que saqué de Google Scholar
cuando estaba preparando el
tercer ejercicio dirigido:
"Efectos de la integración social en la
conservación del funcionamiento
de la memoria en una población de
ancianos de Estados Unidos".
Hay uno sobre la tasa de
sobrevivencia de 10 años en
amistades
en una sociedad australiana.
Aquí hay uno sobre integración
social y mortalidad en Francia.
Otro de interacción social y
mortalidad en Suecia.
En Finlandia. En Japón. En China.
En todas las culturas en las
que se ha investigado,
el engranaje social es vital para
la prosperidad humana.
Podríamos preguntarnos si
esto nos dice algo
sobre lo que nos preocupa en
este segmento del curso,
la cuestión de la prosperidad humana,
y si nos dice algo sobre las
cuestiones que abordaremos
en las siguientes unidades del
curso: nuestras discusiones
sobre moralidad y filosofía política.
Harrow, Bowlby, Ainsworth y el
estudio de Minnesota
han señalado que para que
los seres humanos
desarrollen el tipo de
relaciones de confianza
que den lugar al surgimiento de una
sociedad, es fundamental
que haya un cierto tipo de conexión
social estable en la infancia.
Veremos en nuestra discusión
de filosofía política si esto
tiene alguna implicación
en cómo debe estructurarse una sociedad
si deseamos cultivar ciudadanos justos
capaces de participación
interna y democrática.
¿Esto significa,
sorprendentemente, que algo que
pensábamos
que no es asunto de la
filosofía política,
como la estructura
interna de la familia,
en realidad sí lo es?
Y en caso de que así sea: ¿Es un
triunfo para la izquierda?
¿Para la derecha?
¿Para algo distinto totalmente?
Nos preguntaremos,
al discutir el amor romántico de Haidt,
definido como una combinación
extraordinaria de nuestra capacidad
de apego, de cuidado y de apareamiento,
si los códigos morales que
tenemos deben respetar el hecho
de que tendremos relaciones
especiales con ciertos individuos
que nos impedirán verlos como uno más,
a pesar de que al parecer, la
moralidad nos pide
que tratemos a todos igual.
Nos preguntaremos,
al discutir el documento de Nozick
que leímos sobre el amor
como una formación de un nosotros,
cuando formamos conexiones
que van más allá
de las conexiones
individuales como los
barrios,
las comunidades
religiosas o los países,
si eso tiene alguna
importancia moral o política.
Volveremos a la pregunta hecha
por James Stockdale
que nos señaló la importancia de
la amistad, de la cohesión
y de la camaradería cercana para
favorecer la resistencia ante el
sufrimiento, si de hecho le incumbe a
las estructuras políticas
fomentar la estabilidad en las
comunidades para permitir
que la gente sobrelleve las
tormentas que la suerte traiga.
Al hacerlo, podremos
entender este fenómeno
tan raro, que Aristóteles
plantea en Ética a Nicómaco,
un libro sobre ética que
sienta las bases
para la tradición ética occidental, que
incluye entre sus 12 capítulos,
2 completamente dedicados a la
cuestión de la amistad.
Aristóteles comienza señalando que
si eres joven o viejo, rico o pobre,
si estás en un momento de tu vida
en el que las cosas van bien o van mal,
nada es más importante
para permitirte prosperar
que la amistad.
Gracias a todos por venir
a una clase más.
Contestaré con gusto a sus preguntas
aunque ya hemos llegado al final de
los 50 minutos permitidos.
Responderé con gusto
porque no hay límite.
Hola, sí dime.
Alumno: [inaudible]
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Se
pueden ir si quieren.
Haz tu pregunta.
Te responderé con gusto.
Alumno: [inaudible] entre los
cuidados en la temprana infancia
que llevan a la prosperidad y la
desatención que lleva a algo malo.
Eso parece tener una
especie de carga moral,
hay un juicio de valor
inherente en todo esto.
Y he estado pensando porque
ese libro que mencionó
sobre las distintas facetas de nuestra
personalidad [ininteligible]
porque no podemos decir
que necesariamente
haya una buena forma de saber
cómo educar a tu hijo.
Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
Bien.La pregunta era.
Yo hice una afirmación de que cierto
tipo de cuidados en la temprana
infancia parecía llevar a
capacidades sociales de cierto tipo,
mientras que la desatención en
la temprana infancia
parecía llevar a problemas sociales.
Al hacer esta afirmación:
A) ¿Estoy haciendo un juicio de
valor que es inválido
sobre cómo queremos
funcionar en sociedad?
B) ¿Estoy haciendo un juicio de
valor que es inválido
sobre lo que es apropiado
al criar niños?
Veamos primero la segunda pregunta.
Las afirmaciones sobre los
cuidados en la temprana infancia
que se hacen aquí son
principalmente sobre
los primeros 18 meses de
vida más o menos.
Hay una gran polémica en este
campus y en todos lados
sobre qué es lo apropiado
después de esos 18 meses.
Parece haber una evidencia
bastante clara,
tanto nacionalmente como
interculturalmente,
de que durante los primeros 18 meses
la idea de demasiados cuidados o
demasiada receptividad,
es un tema del que es difícil
encontrar la medida indicada.
Debido a que la receptividad
a tus necesidades
parece ser una forma de promover
estabilidad y confianza.
Ok. Volvamos a la primera pregunta.
¿Estamos haciendo juicios de
valor sobre lo que significa
ser una buena persona cuando decimos
que buscamos cultivar en nosotros
la posibilidad de confiar
y relacionarnos, en vez de
la desconfianza?
Supongo que hay circunstancias
o sociedades en las que la confianza
podría ser un perjuicio.
Donde responder a alguien
sin estar constantemente en
guardia sería peligroso.
En esas circunstancias, tal vez
tendría sentido cultivar
otro tipo de experiencia en
la temprana infancia.
Si eso muestra que encontramos 2
formas igualmente buenas
para prosperar es algo que abordaremos
cuando hablemos del relativismo
moral en unas semanas.
Bien. Gracias.